et c'est reparti comme en 39 en 1939
à ceci près que nous ne sommes pas sur
la côte d'azur et que l'hiver s'annonce
déjà
mais peu importe le premier festival de
cannes va enfin avoir lieu
et dans la vie de son inventeur pour
l'heure c'est le festival de cannes 1939
l'édition de 1939 qui lie à orléans
c'est la première édition qui devait
avoir lieu avant la guerre et qui a été
annulée le jour de l'inauguration hitler
envahit la pologne salopards le festival
de cannes 1939 a été conçu par un
orléanais jean zay est alors alors qu'il
était ministre de l'éducation et des
beaux arts etc on rend hommage à orléans
à jean zay aux orléanais
on a envie que les orléanais soient
fiers de cet événement parce que cannes
le festival de cannes un des événements
les plus vues dans le monde entier a été
inventé à orléans c'est ainsi que mardi
prochain alex lutz présentera
l'ouverture de ce festival qui jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine
projettera 29 des 30 films sélectionnés
il y à 80 ans et se replonger à la fois
dans sa ville qu'il aimait tellement à
je cite souvent la phrase orléans dont
je connais toutes les pierres et tous
les tous les visages ceux des vivants et
des morts
c'est une très belle même quand il est
au fond de la prison are you ils
demandent des nouvelles d'orléans où les
bombardements et des râteaux les verts
profond amour de sa vie des orléanais et
puis évidemment ce projet qui était un
combat c'est aussi ce combat-là qui
revit combat qu'a d'ailleurs qui a son
actualité
entré au panthéon en 2015 parce qu'il a
incarné jusqu'au sacrifice suprême
l'idée même de la république josé
assassiné par la mise de pétain en juin
1944 avait en effet vu ce festival pour
faire face à la mostra de venise où
s'étalaient alors le cinéma fasciste
voulue par mu fini
[Musique]